let's explore
the
repercussions of this equation some more
so let's uh what was the equation it was
that the force of a magnetic field on a
moving charged particle is equal to the
charge that's not what i wanted to do is
equal to the charge of the particle
and that's just a scalar quantity times
the velocity
the cross product of the velocity of the
particle
with the magnetic field
now isn't the velocity vector just the
same thing as the distance vector
divided by time so the velocity vector
is equal to let's call the distance that
the electron travels
l
distance divided by time
so we could rewrite that the force
vector is equal to the charge
times and i'm doing this on purpose one
over time right
times
the distance vector
taken
you take the cross product
with the magnetic field
all i did is i rewrote velocity as
per time times distance or distance per
time and this is a scalar quantity at
least for our purposes time only has a
magnitude maybe we could call it change
in time but doesn't have a direction
we're not going at an angle in time
so we could take the scalar quantity out
it doesn't affect this vector cross
product so what we get left with is
force
is equal to
charge per time
times and this is just a regular times
because this is just a number it's not a
vector times the cross product of
the distance vector
and the magnetic field
and what is what is charge per time
no coulombs per second well that's just
current
so we get that force
is equal to current
times the distance that the current is
flowing along
the distance that the current is flowing
along
taken and you take the cross product of
that with the magnetic field
and sometimes this is written as a
capital l because it's a vector and all
that but we start with the lowest case l
so we'll stay with the lower lower case
l so let's see if we can apply
this formula which is really the same
thing as this we just took the divide
the division by time and took it out of
velocity so we get distance and we took
it and we divided the coulombs or we we
took the charge divided by that so we
took charge divided by time or charge
per unit of time you get current so this
is really just a re a a another way of
writing this it's not even a new formula
you could almost prove it to yourself if
you ever forget it
but let's see if we can use this to
figure out the effect that a magnetic
field has on a current carrying wire so
let me actually i probably want to put
this up at the top just so that i have
space to draw a current carrying wire so
let me rewrite it in green
so you're familiar with the formula in
all colors
so now our new our new derivation is
that the force of a magnetic field on a
current carrying wire
is equal to the current in the wire
and that's just a scalar quantity
although it could be positive or
negative depending on the direction or
well
current is always a positive number but
if this current is going in the opposite
direction as our distance vector then it
might be negative but actually i
wouldn't worry about that for now let's
just assume this is a current in the
direction of the distance vector so it's
a scalar quantity current
times our distance vector
l or maybe the length of the conductor
and you take the cross product of l with
the magnetic field vector
so let's see if we can apply that let's
say that we have a wire
actually let me let's do the magnetic
field first because that's interesting
let's say the magnetic field i've i've
been doing a lot of magnetic fields that
pop out of the screen let's do a
magnetic field that
goes into the screen and those are even
easier to draw they're just x's
right now why is it an x because you're
looking at the rear end of an arrow
that's why it's an x and that's why a
circle with a dot means a field or a
vector
coming out of
the window because if an arrow was shot
at you all you would see is the tip of
the arrow
with maybe a little circle around it but
anyway this shows us a vector going into
the screen so this is our magnetic field
that is b
i don't know let's assign some value
let's say that the magnitude of b
is equal to
one tesla
one tesla and let's say i have a wire
going through that magnetic field
let's say the wire
the wire is going along or it's in the
plane of your computer monitor so this
is let me
let me just draw
a wire
going through the magnetic field
and my question to you oh let me let me
tell you a little bit of information
about this wire
let's say the wire is carrying a current
so i is going in that direction
and it is carrying a current of
i don't know i'm just making up numbers
5 amperes or 5
coulombs per second now my question to
you is
what is the net force
of this magnetic field
on a section of this wire and let's make
this section of the wire i don't know
let me see let's say it's a
two meter section of wire
it's a two meter section of wire so what
so obviously the more wire you have the
more charged moving particles you'll
have so the larger section you have the
more of a every force you'll have on
that longer piece of wire so we have to
kind of pick our length so we want to
know what is the force of magnetic field
on this section of wire from here
to here
so let's just go to this formula the
force is equal to the current well
that's five amperes and remember just
from what we learned about electricity
the current is the direction that
notional positive charges would travel
in and that suits us fine because when
we did the the first equation uh we
cared about the direction a positive
charge would go in and if it was an
electron or a negative charge we would
we'd put a negative sign there so that
works fine but if you ever have to
visualize things as they maybe are in
reality but when you talk about
electrons it's hard to say that they
really are reality because they're
almost more an idea than an object but
it's always good to remember that when
the current is flowing in this direction
that would be true because if if there
were positive charges moving but we know
it's electric it's negative charges
moving in the opposite direction or you
could think of it as maybe you know
holes well i don't want to get into that
but anyway the current you could view
you can visualize it if you like is
positive charges going in this direction
so the the current is going this
direction so you could view this
distance vector
that we care about
its magnitude is two meters right
because that's the length of wire in
question and its direction is the
direction of the current so let's so let
me this is l
sometimes i get a little carried away
on tangents
so that is l
it's 2 meters in that direction
i is 5 amperes and we just we already
figured out that the magnetic field is
one tesla so what's what's this going to
be equal to so the force is going to be
equal to
well we're using all si units so we
don't have to convert anything 5 amperes
times
two meters
in that direction
i won't specify it right now we can see
let's say that's the magnitude of of l
actually let's just let me write it well
two meters
times
the magnetic field
one tesla
and so when you take a cross product or
something this is just a reminder l
cross b that's equal to
the magnitude of l
times the magnitude of b
times the sine of the angle
between them times some
unit directional vector that we figure
out with the right hand rule so we
already did the magnitude
of the distance vector that was 2 meters
we did the magnitude
of the magnetic field and what's the
sign of the angle between them well the
magnetic field is going into the screen
right it's going straight into the
screen you can imagine a bunch of arrows
shooting into the screen those are the
vectors
while our
our distance vector or our this l is in
the screen they actually are
perpendicular in three dimensions so
this angle is 90 degrees so this
actually just becomes one
so in terms of the magnitude we're done
the the l cross b magnitude is two times
one tesla and then we multiply that
times the current and then we actually
have the magnitude of the force the
magnitude of this force is going to be
equal to 5
amperes times 2 meters times 1 tesla
which is equal to
10 newtons
and then the only question left is what
is the direction of the force that the
magnetic field is exerting and this is
where we break out the right hand rule
and it's no different you could you know
you can just imagine one of the
one of the positive particles moving
in that direction just use the right
hand rule so let's take our hand out
and if we let me draw a hand a right
hand
so this is my right hand
if i have my thumb sticking out like
that so the l is going to be my index
finger the first thing in the cross
product
and then
the b is the magnetic field that go
that's going into the screen so you
can't see it all you can take my word
for it is that my middle finger is
pointed downwards into the screen and
then my other fingers are just doing
something else
and there you have it the your thumb is
actually the direction of the force
right
that
your index finger
is the direction of you could either say
well we'll say l for these purposes and
then the magnetic field is going into it
so you can't see my middle finger but
it's pointing downwards i can draw a
little x there to show it's going
downwards and then the force is what my
thumb is doing
so the force on this wire or at least on
that section of wire
is going to be perpendicular to the
direction of the current in that
direction is going to be a 10 newton
force anyway i've run out of time